Mauricio's Thank You anime first of all
I want to thank you for and the Finnish
presidency for such work done during the
last six months and certainly the way to
chair the meeting today us doing this
very specific day in Helsinki but it was
it was perfect during the whole day and
I won't don't want to repeat once you
have said just to say that for the
Commission it will be very important to
go forward with the next presidency on
the basis of the different conclusions
of today and the different works of
today I'm thinking about the
digitalization and the exchange of
informations and documents between the
different judicial authorities but also
to have a real strategy for all the
victims for all crimes and it's very
important to go further with a better
access to justice a better capacity to
give compensation and I'm sure that we
need also to improve the capacity to
send informations to all the victims of
all the different crimes and real of
course and hence the civil justice
cooperation it was also one of the
conclusion of today I'm very proud to
say that we'll work very actively to be
able to have a real functioning of the
EPP you at the end of next year we need
to make an evaluation we need to see if
it's possible to work with the actual
means that we have to do that and of
course to organize the different
processes also to go forward with the
alternative measures to detention
because it was a very important
discussion today we need to have enough
resources and so during the whole day we
have discuss also sometimes about the
next mff it's true that we need to
receive enough resources in the year
next mff to have a good functioning of a
PPO and to try to help the Member States
in different ways I want just to add
that it was a pleasure to receive
Loic oversee because it was the first
official contact in a meeting with the
new chief prosecutor and to conclude
just to say that during the lunch I had
a better idea about the way to organize
a good collaboration
who is the justest concerned about the
rule of law I know that I will lead the
work in the Commission to organize a new
mechanism and the new annual report on
the rule of law without any
discrimination about all the different
member states it will be a debate the
general if a consul but it's interesting
to try to have an input coming from the
Justice Council and maybe to discuss the
report also in the Justice Council not
only about the independence of the
judiciary but on different topics in
line with the justice affair so it was
very interesting to discuss on that and
again thank you for the presidency for
such a work done and we will continue to
work with the new equation presidency in
the next six months